hello and welcome to my video series of
mall bio explained in three minutes
where i explain the concept of molecular
biology in less than three minutes or so
if you haven't yet subscribed the
channel hit that subscribe button
today we'll talk about restriction
fragment length polymorphism which was
discovered
by sir alec jefferies in 1984.
this particular technique is based on
two aspects
one is restriction digestion so
restriction
fragment is generated via treatment with
restriction enzymes
and length polymorphism which simply
means
variations in homologous dna sequence in
a
population this particular technique is
kind of obsolete these days
but rflp was the first dna profiling
technique
which was inexpensive enough to be used
in forensic field
in this video we'll talk about the
principle we'll talk about the
application
and limitations of this technique rflp
was
used in forensic sciences and even
in some of the application it is used
till date
paternity testing risk analysis and
gene mapping are few other applications
of rflp
let us look at the technicalities of
rflp the starting material is genomic
dna
then this genomic dna is restriction
digested and the
fragments are separated in agarose gel
now these fragments are then blotted
into a membrane which would be
hybridized and this is
the classical southern hybridization
technique
and ultimately it give rise to the
autoradiogram and that's the end result
that has to be analyzed
so let's contextualize this experimental
steps
into a particular crime scene in a crime
scene we have obtained a dna
and we have two prime suspects suspect
one and two
we have isolated dna from all these
sources and
restriction digested that and hybridized
in this southern blotting paradigm and
this is our autoradiogram
we can understand that the autoradiogram
pattern of
crime scene is matching with the
autoradiogram pattern of suspect two
possibly suspect two was present in the
crime scene
so this technique has a huge potential
in
forensic sciences now the question is
how to design the probe
which would be used in the southern
hybrid hybridization step of rflp
and the answer is a particular region is
chosen
to detect vntrs or variable number of
tandem repeats
these are repetitive sequences in human
genome
which varies individual to individual
and everybody has kind of like a unique
vnt or pattern
these are two individuals so individual
one has
two vnt repeats in this particular loci
whereas individual
two has six v interiors repeat in this
particular loci
now if we design a particular probe
against this particular
sequence we can understand the fragment
size
would be different and the bands would
be also shifted
looking at them we can unders we can
differentiate between two individuals
now let's discuss the limitations of
this particular technique
rflp is extremely slow and southern
hybridization
takes quite a lot of time it also
involves
radioactively labeled probes which is a
quite hazardous
now it requires a large amount of dna
to start with but the problem is in a
crime scene or
in kind of forensic sciences
availability of large amount of dna
might not be really frequent right you
might not have a lot of dna
from the crime scene so these are all
the potential limitations of rflp
in the era of high throughput sequencing
the biggest question is whether rflp is
at all valid these days well the
straightforward answer is
no but let me tell you rflp was
discovered
in 1984 that was a pre-pcr era
and the sequencing technology was not so
developed at that particular time
at that point of time when alec jeffrey
developed this technique
southern blotting was developed but pcr
was unknown because pcr was
devised at 1985. based on the knowledge
on
southern lotting alex jeffries used the
um prior knowledge to build up a
cutting-edge technology which was
relevant
in 1980s and even in 1990s right
only with the development of high
throughput sequencing
this technique became obsolete but
we can appreciate the overall idea of
looking at polymorphism to differentiate
between individuals
identify genetic strains etc
now the question is how a better and
reproducible version of
rflp can be created yes
it was generated few years down the
timeline
and it was generated keeping on the fact
in mind that
in a crime scene very less amount of dna
can be
obtained so amplification
might solve the problem and by that time
pcr was developed
from this we would transition to the
part of
amplified fragment length polymorphism
technique
in the next video we would discuss about
that so stay tuned till the next video
by the way if you want to prepare for
several examinations or want to clear
your concept
all of my playlists would be super
useful for you
as usual if you like this video give it
a quick thumbs up don't forget to like
share and subscribe follow me on
instagram
or facebook all the links are provided
in the description thank you